.
- Martin vient dans son jardin
pour y trouver un peu de calme.
- C'est frustrant,
c'est enrageant.
- À peine remis
d'une dépression, il est
sans emploi depuis cet hiver.
Les derniers mois ont étéont été
particulièrement stressants.
MARTIN COURTEMANCHE
- J'ai perdu mon emploi, moi,
le 6 décembre de l'année passée.
J'ai fainde auprès
de l'assurance-emploi.
Je ferme ma session.
- Plus de six mois après
avoir rempli sa demande,
oujours pas reçu un sous
de l'assurance-emploi.
- À tous les vendredis,
je les appelais, parce que
je me disais que théoriquement,
le jeudi, je devrais avoir
de quoi dans mon compte.
Je finissais l'appel, là, puis
j'avais juste envie de brailler,
parce que ça avançait pas,
puis je savais pas comment faire
pour me sortir de de là.
- Dans cet organisme de défe
des chômeurs, ils en voient
de toutes les couleurs,
ces jours-ci.
- Bien, si on parls
administratifs, c'est un chaos.
Il y a une espèce de marasme
à l'assurance-emploi.
- Pierre Céré évolue dans leue e
domaine depuis près de 40 ans.
Les délais pour traiter
une demande d'assurance-emploi
n'ont jamais été aussi longs.
PIERRE CÉRÉ, ÉRÉ, ÉRÉ, ÉRÉ, ÉRÉ,
Conseil national des chômeurs
- Ça a toujours fait partie...
Les retards, la bureaucratie,
c'est compliqué, on comprend pa,
ça prend des proportions
qui sont extravagantes.
On est un peu dans
une situation qui est extrême.
Il y a moins de prestataires
d'assurance-emploi, et à la
fois, le système est embourbé.
- À la fin mai, près de 22 000
Canadiens attendaient depuis
plus de trois mois un premier
versement, selon des données
obtenues par le Bloc québécois,
en vertu d'une demande d'accès
à l'information.
- On a atteint des situations
d'emploi qui s'apparentent
à du plein emploi.
- Difficile de dire exactement
ce qui cause ces délais.
- Avant, c'était des formations
en personne que les employés
pouvaient avoir.
- Avec 80 % des foes
de l'assurance-emploi en
télétravail, le syndicat
montre du doigt des problèmes
de formaprentissagprentissagpree
et des problèmes informatiques.
JUDITH CÔTÉ, vice-présidente
nationale, SEIC
- C'est blème
de nombre d'employés, si jamais
c'est ça que vous pensez.
On n'a jamais eu autant
és qu'on en a
en ce moment, à Service Canada.
Puis pourtant, on est...
je pense qu'on a rarement étéef.
- Il faut que je me pose
des questions à savoir comment
est-ce que je vais faire
er, payer
mon épicerie. J'avais la chance
quand même d'avoir un peu
d'économies, j'ai "loadé"
mes cartes de crédit aussi.est a
qu'on réussit à survivre.
- Avec deux enfants en bas âge,
Martin et sa conjointe
parviennent à joindreles deux be
et de misère.
KARINA GOULD, ministre Famille,
Enfants et Développement social
- La situation au Québec
en particulier est le résultat
d'une fraude d'identité
dans le secteur privé.
- La ministre fait valoir
que des vols d'identité
ont ralenti le processus...
- Le délai de 28 jours,
ça n'existe pas.
- Et des cas plus complexes
demandent des vérifications.
- Présentement, toujours rien.
- Pendant ce temps, Martin n'a
toujours reçu aucune prestation.
Service Canada lui a assuré
que ce n'était qu'une question
de jours.
- Je me suis trouvé un nouvel
emploi la semaine passée.
J'ai commencé, je touche
du bois; à date, ça va bien.
Puis, j'ai pas l'intention
de lâcher ça pour retourner voir
mes amis de l'assurance-emploi!
(rire)
- Ici Sébastien De
Radio-Canada, Saint-Hyacinthe.